coca-cola shareholders approved  coca-cola's compensation plan which is  something that David winters had wanted  you to oppose right why did you not vote  on this well I i abstained which it is a  vote of sorts I mean it's certainly the  first time I've abstained at coca-cola  that I can remember I voted  enthusiastically for the directors I  certainly am enthusiastic about Muhtar  Kent being the CEO I don't think you  could have a better CEO but I thought  the plan was excessive in the talk about  500 million shares and using them up  over four years so it just it was my  view it's excessive so i abstain I I  could never vote against coca-cola hey  but I couldn't vote for the plan either  shareholder my god not sure well I just  the way I feel about the people there